you can animate elements in the Dom with
CSS or JavaScript this video is going to
show how to animate Dom elements using
JavaScript without any frameworks first
I will show you how to create an
animation by programming gradual changes
in an element style then I will talk
about the new element animate method to
make animation possible
the animated element must be animated
relative to a parent container the
parent must use relative positioning
while the animated element must use
absolute positioning so if you see up
here we have the container my container
and then we have the child element the
my animation that's what the code is
going to animate and if you see here we
have the container that has the relative
positioning and we have the aunt that my
animation that has the absolute
positioning we can use a timer to call
gradual changes in an element style and
when the timer's interval is small the
animation looks continuous so let's look
at the code so you can see when this
button is clicked it calls the my move
function which is right down here so
we're going to get the element by ID get
my animation and assign it to element
and then we're going to set the position
to zero and then we're going to start
this set interval and we're going to
pass in the frame function that we're
going to run and we're going to run this
function every 10 milliseconds and we're
going to assign this to ID that so we
can stop the interval when we need to so
in the frame function if position equals
350 that just means that the square is
at the end of the the BAA the box here
let's put that at the beginning so if
the square is at the end of the box
we're going to clear in an interval and
we pass in the ID that's up here that
just means we're going to stop running
this function we're going to stop
running the frame function every 10
milliseconds else we're going to move it
so we're going to increment the position
from 0 to 1 and then we're going just to
set the top and the left style to the
position the first going to be one pixel
two pixels three pixels four pixels five
pixels
like that and then it's just going to
animate across the screen and you can
easily use different style elements
instead using top and left you can use
the color you can use size any CSS
element you can animate using this
method now I'm going to show you a
different way to animate using the
element dot animate method which is part
of the web animations API and this
method is actually the animation method
with the best performance so let me
paste in the code here now this is
currently only supported in newer
versions of Chrome Firefox and opera
however there is a polyfill that you can
use to add support for most other
browsers check the description for a
link to the polyfill and then you'll be
able to use this all the time so this is
going to animate the Dib item so I need
to add the dip item to the HTML okay so
here's the div with the ID item and in
the CSS I've already added some CSS it's
going to start with the background blue
position:absolute and then eye height
width and the margin is just going to
make it so it centers right in the
square so oh you can see the animation
happening right now now let's go over
the code that shows how this animation
is created so first we get the item get
item by ID item so that's that div and
then we're going to call item dot
animate into the animate function we're
going to pass two things this first
thing we pass in is the keyframes so
this is just an object formatted to
represent a set of keyframes and then
the second thing we're going to pass in
is right here which is the options so
let's look at the key frames in the
keyframes that it's just going to go
from one keyframe to the next so in this
first keyframe it's going to set the
transform we're going to set the scale
to one that's just a hundred percent so
we're not actually doing anything for
that and then we are going to set the
background to a red that's how we start
it and then the opacity to one
which is 100% so the first keyframe is
basically just how we started
now the second keyframe here what's
going on to the next line let's pop this
over a little bit the second keyframe
we're going to do a transform have the
scale go to 0.5 so 50% size we're going
to rotate it 270 degrees set the
background to blue and the opacity to
0.5 or 50% so it's going to animate
between this keyframe and this keyframe
and now the offset is optional if you
don't have offsets it will evenly
distribute each keyframe within the
duration but if you have offsets then it
won't be equally distributed so since I
have point two here it's going to go
from the first keyframe to the second
keyframe and 20% of the time and then
I'll take 70% of the time to go to
offset one the offsets on the keyframe
have to be a numerical order so you have
zero point two and one always ends with
one if we change that to 0.5 you'll see
the animation will be slightly different
so it's just the first part of it is
going to take half half the time instead
of just the 20% of the time so you can
see the last keyframe we put the scale
back to 1 we rotate it to 0 degrees and
set the background back to red opacity
back to red so for the options we have
you set the duration in milliseconds so
that's 2 seconds of the easing we can
change this to something like linear and
let's see what that's going to look like
so here it's not going to change speed
as much between the different keyframes
and then the delay is just how long it
waits before the animation runs after
the page loads and iterations we're
going to keep going on forever but you
can just make it go like 2 or 3
iterations direction it's going to
alternate so that's why it keeps
changing the direction that's spinning
if we put on normal here and we run that
now you can see I'll just always keep
going the same direction and if you hit
if you put reverse here we'll always go
the other direction now all these
options are optional and this fill here
this fill is going to dictate whether
the animations effects should be
reflected by the element prior to
playing which would be backwards or if
we retained after the animation is
completed playing which is forward or
you could put both and one thing to know
about the keyframes up here is that you
can animate pretty much any CSS property
so transform background opacity these
are all CSS properties and you can put
different ones there to animate
different properties so that's animation
thanks for watching my name is beau
Carnes don't forget to subscribe and
remember use your code for good